Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Due to popular request, here's a more intuitive
explanation of our latest work.
Believe it or not, when I have started working
on this, Two Minute Papers didn't even exist.
In several research areas, there are cases
where we can't talk about our work until it
is published.
I knew that the paper would not see the light
of the day for quite a while, if ever, so
I started Two Minute Papers to be able to
keep my sanity and deliver a hopefully nice
piece of work on a regular basis.
In the end, this took more than 3000 work
hours to complete, but it is finally here,
and I am so happy to finally be able to present
it to you.
This work is in the intersection of computer
graphics and AI, which you know is among my
favorites.
So what do we see here?
This beautiful scene contains more than a
100 different materials, each of which has
been learned and synthesized by an AI.
None of these daisies and dandelions are alike,
each of them have a different material model.
The goal is to teach an AI the concept of
material models such as metals, minerals and
translucent materials.
Traditionally, when we are looking to create
a new material model with a light simulation
program, we have to fiddle with quite a few
parameters, and whenever we change something,
we have to wait from 40 to 60 seconds until
a noise-free result appears.
In our solution, we don't need to play with
these parameters.
Instead, our goal is to grab a gallery of
random materials, assign a score to each of
them saying that I liked this one, I didn't
like that one, and get an AI to learn our
preferences and recommend new materials for
us.
This is quite useful when we’re looking
to synthesize not only one, but many materials.
So this is learning algorithm number one,
and it works really well for a variety of
materials.
However, these recommendations still have
to be rendered with a light simulation program,
which takes several hours for a gallery like
the one you see here.
Here comes learning algorithm number two to
the rescue, a neural network that replaces
this light simulation program and creates
photorealistic visualizations.
It is so fast, it not only does this in real
time, but it is more than 10 times faster
than real time.
We call this a neural renderer.
So we have a lot of material recommendations,
and they are all photorealistic that we can
visualize in real time.
However, it is always a possibility that we
have a recommendation that is almost exactly
what we had in mind, but need a few adjustments.
That’s an issue, because to do that, we
would have to go back to the parameter fiddling,
which we really wanted to avoid in the first
place.
No worries, because the third learning algorithm
is coming to the rescue.
What this can do is take our favorite material
models from the gallery, and map them onto
a nice 2D plane where we can explore similar
materials.
If we combine this with the neural renderer,
we can explore these photorealistic visualizations
and everything is appears not in a few hours,
but in real time.
However, without a little further guidance,
we get a bit lost because we still don’t
know which regions in this 2D space are going
to give us materials that are similar to the
one we wish to fine-tune.
We can further improve this by exploring different
combinations of the three learning algorithms.
In the end, we can assign these colors to
the background that describe either whether
the AI expects us to like the output, or how
similar the output will be.
A nice use-case of this is where we have this
glassy still life scene, but the color of
the grapes is a bit too vivid for us.
Now, we can go to this 2D latent space, and
adjust it to our liking in real time.
Much better.
No material modeling expertise is required.
So I hope you have found this explanation
intuitive.
We tried really hard to create something that
is both scientifically novel and also useful
for the computer game and motion picture industry.
We had to throw away hundreds of other ideas
until this final system materialized.
Make sure to have a look at the paper in the
description where every single element and
learning algorithm is tested and evaluated
one by one.
If you are a journalist and you would like
to write about this work, I would be most
grateful, and I am also more than happy to
answer questions in an interview format as
well.
Please reach out if you’re interested.
We also try to give back to the community,
so for the fellow tinkerers out there, the
entirety of the paper is under the permissive
Creative Commons license, and the full source
code and pre-trained neural networks are also
available under the even more permissive MIT
license.
Everyone is welcome to reuse it or build something
cool on top of it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!